crystal et chercheurs elle travaille sur
l'inventaire du patrimoine bâti de sully
sur loire dans le cadre d'une étude plus
vaste sur la reconstruction après guerre
sully a subi par deux fois une
destruction quasi totale de son
centre-ville
alors comme pour échapper au traumatisme
de la guerre
le projet de reconstruction ne cherche
pas à faire à l'identique
hilali plutôt modernité esthétique
contemporaine
70 ans plus tard sully n'a guère changé
mais la mémoire s'efface ce patrimoine
exceptionnel s'oublie ce travail sur la
reconstruction sully va permettre d'une
manière générale une meilleure
connaissance de la période de la
reconstruction
c'est à dire que pour tous les publics
quels qu'ils soient que ce soit un
public de professionnels ou un public de
non initiés
on va raconter une histoire racontée
comment ça s'est passé
qu'est ce qu'on a fait et pourquoi on
l'a fait comme ça christelle est
missionné pour 18 mois par la direction
de l'inventaire du patrimoine de la
région centre val de loire 18 mois pour
analyser le projet de reconstruction
quartier par quartier maison par maison
premier temps la découverte in situ j'ai
commencé en fait ce travail
le nez en l'air en regardant beaucoup
les façades les rues les bâtiments
comment ils s'organisaient
comment ils étaient agencés jusque dans
leurs moindres détails c'est à dire
quelles étaient les matériaux combien y
avait deux fenêtres par où on rentre et
commence à s'organiser et comment on
pouvait en fait imaginer la vie dans ce
dans ce type d'édifice après un travail
de terrain méthodique krystel se lance
dans la recherche documentaire ici dans
le silence des archives départementales
le projet de reconstruction de
sully-sur-loire apparaît on va trouver
beaucoup de casse écrite beaucoup de
plans d'urbanisme mais aussi beaucoup de
plans de maison
les plombs par niveau des façades des
coupes des choses comme ça on peut aussi
trouver des photos des photos avant la
guerre après la guerre même pour moment
des bombardements le même et
effectivement on va trouver en fait un
ensemble de documents qui vont nous
permettre en fait de retracer cette
histoire de comprendre finalement la
ville d'aujourd'hui
le travail de l'historien consiste en
fait à croiser ses archives
qu'elles soient aux archives nationales
qu'elles soient aux archives
départementales qu'elle soit aux
archives municipales qu'elle soit aussi
des archives privées
l'historien et plus ou moins
pluridisciplinaire on a des spécialités
moi la mienne c'est l'histoire de
l'architecturé effectivement la fois des
pensions alors pour des choses plus
techniques ou pour des choses plus
sociologique mais effectivement
nombreuses oeuvres qui essaye d'être
celui de celui d'historiens avec vous ne
pas l'être relativement relativement
large
si possible au moins le passage des
douves
si tu peux avoir un petit peu plus large
jusqu'à le début du dos treize mois sont
passés
christelle envisage la prochaine phase
de son travail la restitution
car son travail de recherche pour être
utilisable doit trouver des formes
concrètes et accessible au plus grand
nombre
ce qui est intéressant avec ce travail
de reportage photographique c'est
qu'effectivement actuellement sully
c'est une ville qui bouge puisque
effectivement les modes de vie ont
évolué entre les années 50 et
aujourd'hui et on a besoin en fait
d'avoir à quelque chose qui soit
conforme en fait à nous à nos modes de
vie donc ce qui veut dire que ce
patrimoine est en train de bouger et à
partir de là nous on peut aussi se
permettre de restituer finalement est
effectivement de collecter des skis
seront des archives dans quelques années
par rapport à ce patrimoine qui est en
mutation et qui est en train d'évoluer
bonjour le travail de christelle est un
travail de fourmi parfois mal compris il
permet pourtant aux historiens
architectes urbanistes ou aux élus
locaux de prendre des décisions en
connaissance de cause
dans tous les cas c'est un travail
scientifique utile et passionné qu'est
ce qui m'anime je ne sais pas la volonté
de savoir la volonté l'apprend
de connaître de mieux connaître et puis
aussi de montrer aux gens de leur
apporter quelque chose finalement même
si on a le sentiment que ça sert à rien
même si voilà c'est le cadre dans lequel
on vit moi j'ai envie qu'ils portent un
autre regard par rapport à ça un autre
regard
c'est ce que proposera l'exposition
itinérante sur la reconstruction dans le
val de loire de juillet 2015 à juillet